this is the Jocko underground podcast
number nine with Echo Charles and me
Jocko willink good evening Echo good
evening all right so last episode we did
we were talking about body language yeah
how to read it uh how to make sure you
aren't sending signals you don't want to
send
but it was from a
store almost from a leadership
perspective interpersonal relationship
scenario how you can read somebody
you're negotiating like this kind of
thing right
and as I started thinking about that I
started thinking about so going from
that end of the Spectrum which is hey
I'm trying to negotiate conversate
whatever I'm trying to try to
communicate with you
verbally
go to the other end of the spectrum
and you end up in different situations
and any in it from a simplistic from a
very
extremely overly simplistic View
there's all these different categories
of people in the world and there's
to
two categories of people that we may or
may not fall into at certain times
that we should think about when it comes
to body language when it comes to
posture when it comes to perception
and that is predator
and pray
what do criminals look for so we don't
want to be prey obviously sure
what do criminals look for and there's a
quote in there serial killer Ted Bundy
admitted in a personal interview in 1985
that he could tell a victim by the way
she walked down the street the tilt of
her head the manner in which she carried
herself
he's observing the way she's walking and
her posture and that's
how he's selecting his victims victim
selection
research corroborates the reality that
criminals do in fact look for or at
least notice certain traits When
selecting potential victims
while nothing excuses crime knowledge is
power in the sense that these things
these that there are things we can do to
protect ourselves when we're out alone
that ties back from just this extreme
end of the spectrum of hey we don't want
to be a we don't want to be a victim
but it also these same
these same postures these same physical
presentations that we make of ourselves
they apply everywhere
look and we'll get to it so from a
leadership perspective how we carry
ourselves
the body language that we have The Way
We Walk actually also has an impact
so
there's an experiment and this is
another article that Dr Patrick wrote
about it was called do you walk like a
victim so they did this experiment
they had 126 men
who had been tested
on something called the dark tetrad
traits
dark tetrats or tetrad means group four
here's the four traits
psychopathology
which means you are
anti-social and you lack of conscience
for and look I'm not a psychologist but
that's the general meeting
[Music]
machiavellianism
which means how calculating are you how
manipulative are you narcissism how
self-obsessed an egotistical are you and
then
sadism like how much do you like to hurt
people so you can see if you start if
you're high in all those traits you're
not a good person you got some issues
and you're you know obviously when you
hire you on the scale the more you're
out as a predator
so they took These Guys these men
who had been kind of measured for these
and then they showed these guys you know
individually videos of eight women who
are walking down like a hallway from
behind so you don't see their face you
can't really judge their face you're
just purely based on how they walk
and
the question was had the woman that
you're seeing walk
has she been victimized in the last five
years
so they watch a woman walk and then they
say do you think that woman's been
victimized in the last five years guess
what the guys that scored high in the
dark
tetrid
they could identify ones that had been
victims you like shake your head because
that's scary yeah very frightening yes
it's disturbing yeah
yeah it's like
like people who score high on this right
some psycho this is faceless there's
something yeah this is a cycle yeah if
you score really high on this you're
you've got issues where they just no
because let's face it uh the
the person that got victimized knows
they got victimized for sure but they
don't know that they're just basically
wearing it with how they walk like just
advertising it like they don't know that
they're doing that yeah and that was one
thing that I thought through this is an
interesting point which does wasn't
covered in the article
if you get victimized do you walk
differently now you see what I'm saying
so that could also be a secondary thing
where you've been victimized so now you
walk differently
which is possible yeah I would imagine
so when you kind of think about it yeah
but I guess maybe like your mind kind of
goes to shoot what else am I just it
like showing to everybody that's exactly
that's right in my head you know and
here's what's here's what else is
interesting is even though it's these
people that have this dark these dark uh
characteristics about themselves
those people can read it easy more
easily but everyone can read it that's
what hit me is like no matter who you
are you can sense what
attitude the person just by the way that
they are walking the based on their gate
their stride length the way they shift
their weight how much your feet move
laterally
there's all these little details so
so there's that
and then there was this then there was
this the original article continued on
they they did this where they took a a
group of prison inmates and they ran the
experiment twice but they showed
these prison inmates
who had been convicted of stranger
assault right not not domestic violence
not I beat up my friend not I met
someone in a bar and got no fight but in
stranger assault were assaulting
somebody and this is from simple assault
all the way up to murder and they had
these tapes that they made of people
walking through New York City
and
what they did was
try to figure out
who these violent criminals would attack
and there was a couple things the the I
like this one the non-victims
people that the the perpetrators would
look at and say I would I probably
wouldn't assault that person they had
something called that they called
organized quality so the person just
looks organized
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen go
to Jocko underground.com And subscribe
and we're doing this to mitigate our
Reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you
each assistance at Jocko underground.com
and we'll get you taken care of until
then we will see you mobilized
Underground